autre appel à noah lou oui allô bonsoir
madame diallo mimi sa loi oui madame
quel est votre prénom
pierrette oui bonsoir pu être pire est
un prénom qui chantent
pierrette sos coeurs brisés vous écoute
alors voilà j'ai 34 ans je vis avec un
homme caire depuis deux ans j'ai un
petit garçon aussi un giro qui a 5 ans
attendait pierrette donc pierre n'est
pas le père de jérôme si elle sait le
faire de chez vous bien nous sommes
d'accord d'accord peut continuer je vous
en prie pirette et détendez-vous mais
nous sommes là pour vous aider et dites
vous bien que tout problème a une
solution
merci merci donc je peux continuer la
wii et dites vous bien que tout problème
a une solution je peux continuer oui et
dit la liesse
alors voilà depuis quelques temps pierre
n'est plus le même avec moi on connaît
plus et il a vraiment changé d'attitude
et soyez plus précis spirel s'il vous
plaît oui ben voilà c'est arrivé il ya
deux ou trois semaines à peu près qu'en
dites vous justement de niche
c'est pas grandir non je demande quand
est-ce arrivé il ya deux ou trois
semaines à peu près à c'est important
qu'ils arrêtent
oui bon alors donc ya deux ou trois
semaines pierre est rentré du travail
ont comme d'habitude qui on s'est
disputés mais vraiment alors pour une
bricole et puis je vous en prie
pierrette il me faut tous les paramètres
du conflit afin d'être à même d'élucider
votre problème problème d'une femme qui
veut s'en sortir et il me semble que
c'est votre cas pire est même bien sûr
bien sûr mais voilà pierre m'a frappé a
est depuis cette première fois d'une
frappe régulièrement mis à
je suis très ennuyé parce que le pied là
ils assistent à ces scènes aaa
dites-moi pierret que fait pierre dans
la vie piet les routiers et pourtant les
routiers sont sympas
bien sûr je viens enfin que dois-je
faire remy sylvette sylvette il me tire
vers le haut ce pire est oui pierrette
qui respire et pierrette a priori et 1,8
ablement et je suis sûr de ne pas me
tromper en pierre un problème vous
croyez oui écoutez petit à grand ans
nous nous trouvons manifestement devant
le 4 types d'un homme qui vit avec une
femme et un enfant
c'est ça et déjà nous y voyons plus
clair un homme et femme quel enfant
c'était important et j'irai même plus
loin qui rêvent taille osons nous poser
la question quelle question minutes vous
êtes toujours la pierrette elle
souhaitait pas y arrive doucement on y
arrive
chi va piano va sano vous le savez pour
être non je ne savais pas si vous savez
alors posons nous poser la question oui
pourquoi
pourquoi vous fera petit bien sûr vous
êtes vous déjà posé cette question
intéresse c'est pourquoi elle s'est bien
sûr aussi pourquoi paris posée mais la
réponse est dans la main la réponse dans
la marmite alors pourquoi oui bien sûr
je comprends tout à fait mais quand même
nom rendant résume en privé du mont
pierre frappe pierrette devant pierre
devant jérôme qui n'est pas l'enfant de
pierre si un tiers celle perdue en
arrière nous sommes d'accord et je pense
que muni de toutes ces informations
je peux le dire pierre s'identifie
totalement à jérôme cet enfant que vous
frappez alors petit je touche par 600
savoir une frappe et c'est vraiment
et rien d'autre rien d'autre pierrette
on intervient dans ce problème que deux
points ouvrez les guillemets pierre
jérôme et jérôme pierre fermez les
guillemets ça s'en va et ça revient
c'est fait de tous petits riens bien sûr
et déjà envoyé je crois que ça arrive
pire est alors dit ouf dit ouf ouf
guérette je veux vous l'entendre dire
c'est très bien pires
alors écoutez moi bien oui pierre est un
enfant un gosse un grand gosse
prenez le par la main et je vous en prie
je vous en supplie aider le comprenez le
et réalisé deux enfants à la maison même
s'ils se servent tous deux de leurs
petits pois deux enfants la maison n'est
ce pas merveilleux suez souvenez vous
souvenez vous comme moi je me
souviendrai toujours de vous sylvette
souvenez-vous que pierre qui roule
n'amasse pas mousse cardon va la cruche
à l'eau pérenne ou le drian
à la fin elle se casse surtout perret de
perrette et le pot tall est bien sûr en
faire que nos frères me me dégoûter
pierer cueilli cueillez dès aujourd'hui
les roses de la vie je voulais